ky and Jacob are nine months old too
young to realize they're growing up in a
non-traditional family
the twins are being raised by two
fathers making them one of the first
same-sex families in Taiwan to Shia -
when we go out for a walk with the kids
people ask us who their mother is we're
completely open with them it gives us
the chance to explain that these
children have two fathers
the twins were born to a surrogate
mother in the United States Jalen and
Jonah Chen now want to be legally
considered a family tonight I see
occasion when I take the children to the
doctor or if there's a problem I'm not
allowed to make any decisions JD
tae-hwan is debating the legalization of
same-sex marriage thanks in part to Chi
Chi away and his lawyer who have taken
their case to the Constitutional Court
she she is you want I hope the court
delivers a clear ruling and provides a
solid basis to put aside any contentious
issues on the subject she won't call you
did you shave Jung a Johnson the
government has expressed its willingness
to pass a registered partnership law but
it's unclear whether these same-sex
partnerships will be granted full
marriage status chi chi away a longtime
gay activist thinks taiwan is ready to
take the step
Konoe yoga I was the only protester at
first nowadays there are 70 to 80
thousand coming to the gay pride parades
Taiwanese society has become one of the
most liberal in Asia elsewhere in the
region same-sex couples are threatened
with prison sentences in Taipei the gay
quarter is plainly visible in the city
centre still what appears acceptable in
public may be scorned within the family
Jona chen still hasn't told his parents
he lives with a man
yo another Yangtze I need courage to
tell them the truth and I should do it
soon because at some point I have to
tell my parents that I have two children
now he's awaiting your avatar plans to
introduce legal same-sex marriage were
met with protests from the beginning the
spokesman of a conservative Parents
Association thinks the discussion has
gone too far
why are you so wait the in Chinese
culture marriage is a bond between a man
and a woman that's what provides the
continuity of male and female ancestry
this is our cultural system and it goes
back thousands of years
pardon so any men to go teach any at all
kai and jacob won't understand such
family politics until they're much older
all that matters to these twins now is
that their most basic needs are met